j'ai commencé du coup les réseaux à 15
ans du coup ça bien pris sur les réseaux
ça a été un peu compliqué de combiner ma
vie professionnelle qui prenait une
ampleur énorme et les études j'ai quand
même aller jusqu'au bac pour pour moi
parce que c'est important je voulais me
battre ça a été très très dur parce que
voilà notre été à l'école le roc avait
dit que youtube avait trouvé votre vie
complètement bas parce que en fait
j'étais pas j'étais pas très épanouie
dans mes études et j'ai très très attiré
par ce milieu artistique et je me suis
donné tous les moyens d'y arriver et ça
a marché pour moi mais c'était très dur
de mes 15 ans jusqu'à mes 18 de combiner
les deux quoi ils font quoi vos parents
enfin mon père il a trés dans la bourse
c'est maintenant il travaille et que
vous exact c'est ça exact nous avons
embauché votre père sévère avec lui non
on s'entend très bien ça nous rapproche
contenance rsa et vous l'avons engagé
derrière où la vie à un moment quand ça
marche qui est normalement pour vous ça
doit être est ce une fierté dans wave
franchement mais pour vous c'était
important pour moi d'avoir une épaule
droite donc revenu que mon père pour
poser avec moi et non mais je sais
qu'aujourd'hui vous voulez venir pour
faire passer un message aussi qui je
pourrais dire aux jeunes qui aujourd'hui
trouve difficilement leur voix il ya
plein de gens qui veulent faire comme
vous il ya plein de jeunes moi
aujourd'hui c'est le nouveau truc je
mette influenceurs je vais être youtuber
c'est vrai que on se dit voilà
aujourd'hui il ya aussi ce il ya aussi
cette voie là et on peut voir des talons
aujourd'hui que vous pouvez pas voir
avant voilà grâce à youtube grâce aux
réseaux sociaux et vous ça c est un
carton moi je me suis vue de donner
vraiment tous les moyens d'y arriver à
15 ans j'avais pas du tout confiance en
moi je pensais vraiment pas jamais en
arriver aujourd'hui mais j'ai tout donné
j'ai cru en moi j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
travailler plein de gens pensent que
c'est facile d'en arriver là mais j'ai
vraiment tout donné j'ai cru en moi j'ai
tout fait pour y arriver
et ouais c'est une belle réussite suis
très fier de moi aujourd'hui c'est trop
beau si aujourd'hui et tout ce qui s'est
passé
toute la crise coin a vécu et la classe
du coït ou sachez que pour les jeunes
s'étaient c'était c'était dur aussi
parce que si ceux qui ont le plus
souffert aussi parce qu'ils pouvaient
plus sortir
il pouvait plus voir leurs potes ça vous
a marqué complètement magique je
recevais beaucoup de témoignages de mes
abonnés qui méprisait qui se confie à
moi et
même si aujourd'hui je passe chez déjà
rejeté me mettre à leur place c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué c'est la
ministre vous connaissiez samedi jules
ou pas non faut que vous fassiez désolé
avec lui au début
le président a fait des vidéos avec mc
fly et carlito five en ruines là bientôt
vous fassiez une vidéo et sony joue mal
je crois quoi faire ça non mais je pense
que ce qui est important dans ce que
vous dites c'est que la confiance en soi
c'est fondamental et parfois on peut
avoir un parcours scolaire qui vous
cassent la confiance je pense que c'est
vraiment important et dans nos solutions
on a aussi la volonté de redonner
confiance que chacun puisse reprendre
confiance en soi quand on a la confiance
quand on a un rêve un projet alors on
s'en sort et je pense que c'est ce que
vous montrez mais c'est vrai qu'après ça
c'est un projet plus artistique il ya
plein de jeunes qui veulent faire des
produits artistiques comment quand ils
font les jeunes pour être aidés parce
que je le dis aussi dans les trucs comme
ça ça met longtemps à partir et on met
longtemps à gagner de l'argent il faut
avoir des parents derrière ou bien il
faut trouver un petit job à côté là avec
la crise ça devait être extrêmement
compliqué donc c'est vrai que parfois on
se dit ben non je vais laisser tomber
mes rêves et je vais laisser tomber mon
rêve de carrière artistique parce que je
dois manger tous les jours et que c'est
que c'est compliqué donc comment on peut
les aider les jeunes qui ont qui n'ont
pas la chance voilà d'exploser comme ça
très vite
enfin c'est sur que c'est pas les
parcours les plus simples quand on veut
arriver dans ces métiers je pense que il
ya des formations pour y arriver
vous n'avez pas eu besoin manifestement
donc ça doit pas être forcément
indispensable non je ne sais pas trop
bien quoi pour répondre ou mais si vous
vous avez réussi par vos qualités par la
sa confiance en vous par le fait d'avoir
un rêve et je pense que ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut vouloir apporter aux jeunes
mais c'est ça c'est de les aider à
prendre confiance
complètement c'est une période c'était
une passion donc je me suis vraiment
donner tous les moyens d'y arriver après
j'ai vraiment c'était important pour moi
de continuer les études aussi et jusqu'à
que 18 ans jouer professionnellement ça
pouvait marcher pour moi j'ai abandonné
été tués